hello neighbor we're gonna watch a
beautiful day in the neighborhood
Tom Hanks playing mr. Rogers himself I'm
excited to check this out you know what
I haven't mentioned in a while you
should download and follow us in the
Stardust app we're still posting on
there and I haven't mentioned that in
like a month we do 30 second reaction
reviews for films TV shows and trailers
we post quite frequently would
appreciate some support over there I
like support you would like support to
do the mr. Rogers thing the kind thing
and follow us show your love let's watch
Tom Hanks play Tom Hanks as mr. Rogers
[Music]
it's a beautiful day in this note but
the beautiful day for a neighbor will
you be mine could you be mine
[Music]
please forgive me
[Music]
mr. Rogers I'm here to interview you it
is so nice to meet you
okay found mr. majors please don't ruin
my childhood this be for an issue about
your own do you consider yourself a hero
[Music]
we are trying to give the world positive
ways of dealing with feelings like what
many things you get to do you could play
all the lowest keys on a pan at the same
time
[Music]
we love broken people
[Music]
okay
I think the best thing we can do is to
do now is practice
[Music]
yeah I am yeah I am me all warm inside
made me want to change my sweater too
did you ever see the documentary I
haven't seen the documentary although I
saw countless episodes of the actual
show growing up I'd say it's not the
same yeah you're missing out on the full
experience yeah see the TAC team is
actually no there's a lot like he went
to like to court up against Congress for
certain things he fought things with
love they fought things with positivity
I don't think there was anything I saw
last year that made me cry as much as
that honestly the Reverend stuff I'm
sure I know well I'm just thinking this
is all just bringing back so many things
from that it's really inspiring to see
how you give those beliefs that you
always hear that people can become kind
of cynical about or where you know you
can really change things with acts of
kindness you could really change things
through love and he was just a prime
example of how you can do that and even
doing those things there's even a little
segment in there that is met with people
hating on Mister Rogers it just showed
that even the days before social media
no matter how good of a person you were
you're still gonna get like outlets just
attacking you and people protesting when
you're gonna get people who probably
think that you're disingenuous and who
were bitter and who are glad to attack
you based on that exactly but I love the
deep dive that that documentary took
spanning just before he had a show all
the way up to the very end where he
still felt like he could have done so
much more it's still so beautiful when I
think about this movie coming out I've
one part of my brain goes what's the
point of having this the documentary
just came out documentaries a very
effective I don't watch a lot of
documentaries simply because of the fact
that it's a I do have that kind of brain
attention span that can have a difficult
time latching on to formats of
documentaries well for someone like
myself who has difficulty usually
watching documentaries I found it to be
very easy to sit through I loved it it's
stuck with me for such a long time
what's the point of this then I'm
thinking what most people don't watch
documentaries you know more people are
probably gonna watch the Tom Hanks play
mr. Rodgers story more than they will
the documentary so you can still get an
effective piece where you can still
spread the story in the journey of mr.
Rodgers through the art of storytelling
perhaps and that might make it
worthwhile plus it's just gonna be cool
to see Tom Hanks doing doing this thing
is mr. Rodgers yeah I mean from what I
understand about this movie it's not a
straight biopic they're doing sort of a
my weekend with Marilyn thing where it's
about a reporter who's going to do a
report like a story on mr. Rodgers I was
like that Bruce Lee movie or like that
Bruce Lee movie that was totally
definitive about Bruce Lee's life yeah
but yeah this is one of those movies
where it's basically about like a
cynical reporter who is going to
essentially do a piece on mr. Rogers and
then finds that his life is sort of
changed through the process so if the
case for Christ is like the case for
Christ exactly in fact I mean you know
this is basically the same thing from
that perspective and not having seen the
documentary I can see there as something
interesting to do with this movie you
know we have a lot of discussion now
about edginess versus vulnerability and
authenticity in terms of entertainment
in terms of how we interact with each
other I feel like yeah you may be able
to capture the audience who isn't as
apps to go and check out a documentary
but I think with the perspective this
movies coming from I think that could be
an effective thing because it is our
lead character from what I understand
does come with a very cynical attitude
towards this story and so I feel like as
a jumping in point for a lot of people
that could potentially be a nice thing
because we do live in a very cynical
time and place now we live in a time
with more information than ever and in a
time where you can't really trust the
figures you see on TV the people who are
you know spreading their ideas to the
masses in that light I think this could
be pretty cool I mean I like the look of
everything I think Tom Hanks's I was
actually very skeptical when they cast
him as mr. Rogers because it just seemed
like a sort of
lene one yeah because I'm like I get it
we love Tom Hanks they have a similar
vibe but I don't think like ah Tom Hanks
he's a perfect match for Fred Rogers
seeing the amount of character
affectation that he's putting into this
I mean it's still Tom Hanks I am more
intrigued by the performance aspect than
I was initially because I was like oh of
course Tom Hanks is warm and fuzzy we
all love Tom Hanks it would have been
easy for him just to show up and be Tom
Hanks but it doesn't seem as though
that's exactly gonna happen and yeah
just the aura that flies off this
trailer the sort of embodiment of that
kind spirit does ring pretty true at
least from this little first taste we
got so yeah I mean his voice doesn't
seem again what he's going for in his
voice it'll sounds like Tom Hanks doing
that act it sounds like he's doing an
accent yeah I don't feel like he's
nailing the voice per se yeah but he's
got a lot of the body language a lot of
the cadence a lot of the walk the
mannerisms out I'm not sure have one
time span they're gonna be doing here
yeah but they didn't even have that line
in there that I really like the
reporters girlfriend saying you're gonna
ruin my childhood could've been that
movie yeah of like what was the dark
side of mr. Rogers and I think that's
like drinking and throwing a bottle and
yelling yeah at least from the little
blurb I read that's kind of what I think
this protagonist of the story probably
went in hoping to find and then has his
life changed for the better in the
process yeah then this is a true story
this is a real article I believe that
you can read if you haven't seen the
documentary won't you be my neighbor you
gotta watch that it is I do this is
truly breathtaking one of the most
inspiring things I've hands-down ever
ever experienced and I have liked every
tear was a tear of joy yeah we do use
more than we got oh you gotta watch it
so I'll be checking this out of him they
didn't grow up on the show so that's
what was fascinating to me about the
experience so are you guys excited to
watch Tom Hanks play mr. Rogers are you
gonna check out a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
comment below region subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and also don't forget to download
and follow us on the Stardust app patron
the day shout-out forum is Adelia
Chamberlain I feel like if we were to
read
buuut mr. Rogers no one will be better
suited for the job than Adelia all we
got to do is get you on some kind of
screen test to see how you change
sweaters but you're an intellect you're
a warm spirited person and I believe you
could deliver that level of kindness to
the world plus I mean Tom Hanks playing
you in a movie someday how cool would
that be
get on it Adelia get on some
public-access start touching the lives
of the young people today I'll tune in
because I'm a depraved dastardly soul
and I could use some rehabilitation in
my life I could learn how to be kind I'm
not a very kind person in fact when the
cameras turn off I just beat Greg
senselessly for the rest of our workday
it's like five and a half hours worth
every time you do is you transition its
defeat about you I you know cuz I'm
really out of practice them you know
it's only every once in a while that I
need a shout outs and I get
self-conscious and then I like the last
30 seconds about you yeah you're my new
your ear missa Delia's neighborhood
let's do it we're done the Delia does
have the Harvard mr. Rogers